let's say something weird happens Drew
says honey listen we're gonna go to
dinner with Cameron Diaz
you guys are sitting at dinner and
Cameron Diaz puts her hand in your laps
that's right that's right it's my
favorite question so far Bachelor number
one what do you do do you tell Drew do
you stop what do you do not move her
hand what do you do what do you do
Bachelor number one I'd be very
uncomfortable
they're Bachelor number two would you be
uncomfortable I can't imagine that that
would happen to me though so but uh
I guess I'd turn to Drew and be like did
you set this up to see uh am I being
tested or that that would be my first
guess oh yeah
good answer uh Bachelor number two what
do you do with this Cameron Diaz who's
obviously not a good friend to Drew
also if you know her this is so [ __ ]
brilliant keep going
well first of all my mom actually asked
me why don't you date Cameron Diaz like
20 years ago she asked this of me and I
was like Mom you think I'm just
access to her contact info
um anyway
uh I would ask a similar question Drew
did you arrange this are you looking for
a little throw up a little threesome
action Bachelor number three what do you
do
and say check please my most comedic
voice no I would uh I would gently push
her hand off of my leg and Scoot closer
to Drew and tell her in her year but
like hey just a heads up I don't know
what's going on but I thought you should
know and at number four what would you
do with Cameron Diaz so Drew this is
what I would do I would say Cameron get
your [ __ ] hands off of me you have
some nerve you have some nerve touching
me without my consent right and then I
would I leave the restaurant with Drew
unacceptable Behavior
foreign